and it's early but a little bit of
housekeeping for to code is it's
actually that pound CMU energy so that
you put in that code and it'll say
what's your question your question will
actually appear on an iPad that our
moderator has up here on the front so
very high-tech we get a lot of questions
per session we encourage you to give as
many questions as you'd like but will be
able to only get to a few of them
because our conversations are right at
45 minutes we are this the panel
sessions are really like a speed round
we're very excited for this first panel
and without further ado I'm gonna let
them take the stage
good morning everyone it is my honor to
introduce such a great panel today which
includes a former Navy SEAL sorry had to
say that a Pittsburgh Steeler the serial
entrepreneur what was supposed to be the
queen attack but she had a family
emergency and someone working to solve a
very big transportation issue in the
region our moderator today Don Morrison
he's at the end there he's the serial
entrepreneur who's been involved in the
growth of several businesses most
notably American Eagle Outfitters there
he grew the company as president CEO
from 1 to 165 stores
he's currently chairman of deal flow for
blue treant
allied angels and chairman of the Linden
Point Development Corporation LDC Don's
also entrepreneur in residence at the
University of Pittsburgh's innovation
Institute and he's a coach and a mentor
to a whole bunch of startups in the
region kuri Crookston you raise your
hand curry right here his head of
innovation management at KU best row a
company which is doing some very
interesting and innovative things these
days he's the next at the ex-navy seal a
grad of the u.s. Naval Academy with an
MBA from Virginia he's been busy
implementing business model innovation
otherwise known as BMI creating and
growing text based businesses as an
entrepreneur and as part of a larger
organization
next we have jeff mcdaniel jeff served
in the Navy as a Surface Warfare Officer
and he's an attorney one badass
combination if you ask me he's now
executive in residence at innovation
works working with the management teams
of startup clean energy and
manufacturing tech companies jeffrey
provides mentoring and network access to
the portfolio companies that innovation
works and serves as an observer on the
board of directors
it's definitely someone I would want to
my team Carly
we have karlie she's the only female
here now is the staff lead for Ana
to develop a regional transportation
innovation and investment strategy at
the Allegheny conference for community
development that's a very big deal as
many of you know right now she's working
with the very dynamic Anna sofyan here
at Carnegie Mellon and other local
partners on assessing the energy startup
ecosystem in our region today the goal
is to identify a strategy for further
investment and private partnership
support that leaves that I would have
left two people one of whom was Audrey I
was going to say both of them graduated
from Ohio State University but only one
played football hey she is not here due
to a family emergency we will really
miss her but that leaves Will Allen who
co manages the day-to-day operations and
investment and acquisition strategy for
nascent Group Holdings he completed a
program to the NFL at Harvard Business
School and he interned with congressman
Bobby Rush on the energy and Power
subcommittee and as you all know will
played in the NFL for twelve seasons
most recently for the Pittsburgh
Steelers he was member the Ohio State
2002 national championship team and was
named a consensus all-american all that
is super impressive but so is this he
serves on the advisory committee for be
a middle school mentor through the
United Way he's on numerous boards
through town and he established the Will
Allen Foundation which provides tools
and resources to educate influence and
empower people in his surrounding
community so I now turn this over to Don
in this very impressive panel enjoy
Thank You Tracy and thank you for being
on the panel I'm honored to be up here
with such distinguished panelists
pittsburgh's has a great manufacturing
legacy in steel and aluminum and glass
in more recent years Pittsburghers
developed a reputation for Ed's and meds
but also for artificial intelligence
robotics autonomous field vehicles in
computer technology yet many people when
it comes to conversations about energy
Pittsburgh is not top of
so why do you think Pittsburgh should be
included in the energy conversation I
think that uh Pittsburgh is included in
the energy conversation and we have a
strong presence with that I mean oil and
gas is strong clean energy is a very
strong here you know within the state
the Allegheny County leaves leads every
County and clean energy jobs and I don't
I don't know if that's promoted or
celebrated enough but that's you know
that's your solar that's your wind
that's your advanced HVAC manufacturing
and that needs to be discussed more and
I don't think it needs to be competitive
outside of the traditional oil and gas
industry that's that's that that's the
present so you know Pittsburgh and the
region you know it's very strong
as it relates to energy and the
investments and you know where we're
going I mean that industry the clean
energy industry has grown six percent
every year over the last five years so
it's it's really exciting where we can
go I just think it needs to be
celebrated and we need more advocates
for that right I think we whether you've
been a Pittsburgher all your life or
coming one and only been here for a few
days or years there's this Pittsburgh
humbleness
we rarely toot our own horn and I
believe that we have for a long time
been among cities that should have the
right to claim the title of energy
capital of the world we have been known
for that before at least twice in the
last two hundred some-odd years and I
think we're on the verge of becoming
known for that breadth of energy
expertise again if a few more of us tune
our own horn and on that note about the
humbleness we really do have a unique
concentration of energy
search happening here it's not just you
know we're all aware probably of one
little slice of that pie but the fact
that we have two federal research labs
that bring a billion dollars you know
annually into the region that we've got
multiple universities multiple
engineering programs multiple other
energy related research activities
programs workforce all these things add
up together to have a lot more
concentration here that has a
multiplying effect and so for that alone
if we can just take a look at that and
really think about how we promote that
out and how we coordinate it we
absolutely should be part of the energy
conversation so courier we just under
marketed from an energy perspective I
think there's a the other part of the
equation also has is that there's also
large users so think about for example
cadastro are conic you know just in
North America we use nine figures in
electricity and so if you think about
the side of the research and development
the other part of that equation is that
people to actually use the energy and so
there's a lot of large players in the
region that are ideal customers for
those technologies that were developing
and we're actually not a slouch as a
state in terms of producing that energy
and electricity there were second in the
nation in terms of electricity
production we're second
for natural gas production or second for
nuclear power generation I mean these
are out of 50 states Pennsylvania is
already poised to really be the center
of a lot of the energy production side
so it is it's the users it's the
research it's the ideas that are already
developing here and then sort of how you
pull it all together so does the
Allegheny conference have a marketing
strategy about energy or related to
energy so the Allegheny conference is a
regional economic development
organization and we have over the years
done various things to market sort of
our energy resources and assets but
really what's new now is focusing more
on the innovation side and on how we can
do a better job not just us but with a
lot of partners who are in the room and
and beyond to do a better job marketing
the energy startup assets
here that is sort of something that I
think a lot of us have talked about
being a gap that we've never really
wrapped our arms around and gotten a
handle on one shared message and
platform to promote jointly I'm gonna be
asking a few more questions but I just
wanted to point out anyone in the
audience has any questions you can just
submit it to the slide Oh calm up on the
screen and magically sent to my laptop
up here the word energy means different
things to different people the first
thing that comes to some people's mind
is traditional fossil fuels particularly
development natural gas in the region to
other people energy means alternative
energy electric call cars battery
technology wind and solar what
advantages does Pittsburgh have in
either of those two sectors in terms of
resources and competitive advantages
with other regions I think I'll take a
stab at that although I think one of the
things that the positions Pittsburgh to
be considered an energy capital of the
world is that for the most part we take
a all of the above approach to energy so
it's not necessarily as limited in scope
or in category and I think that the
innovation piece of that where perhaps a
little bit more willing to apply new
technology to existing applications so
what was the what was a question again
actually what advantages do we have in
either a traditional fossil fuel energy
sector or in the alternative clean tech
energy sector so I think one of the
advantages is just experience we've been
challenged by demand whether it was - in
a fire
our fuel plants for a couple centuries
now so we've had to figure out how to
innovate whether it was how to burn wood
how to burn coal other fossil fuels and
utilize them and I think that we also
have then spun out all of these other
industries that have also had a
requirement of sorts so whether it was
materials expertise that that we gained
and then looking at taking that
experience and turning it right back
into applying it into maybe new energy
sources or technologies I would I would
say it's the diversification that we
have here it's not necessarily you know
one aspect of energy called a
traditional oil and gas that were that
we're banking on and if you look at the
Gulf Gulf Coast it's is all oil and gas
and major disaster happens what happens
to the production we we see what
happened you know without with a natural
gas pipeline recently which is shut off
so that that that disrupts the whole
entire industry I think we are in a safe
geographical location in western
Pennsylvania in the region to to
diversify to have natural gas production
and exploration but also to and have a
very robust innovation mindset you know
get Carnegie Mellon here you got Pitt
you have so so much activity going on I
think what what we lack is that we're
not capturing it and streamlining it to
where it could be commercialized and
accelerated and I think once we once we
realized that aspect of it just you know
oil and gas it's very easy you do a
geological study you drill pump it out
you make money it is very simple
technology and innovation is a little
bit more complex than that and it takes
and it's a long wave and I think once we
figure that out
you know who kids stop Pittsburgh who
can stop the region at that point it's
it's it's hard to it's hard to do that
when with with such diversification we
as a region also have really gotten out
in front of some of the workforce and
talent pipeline issues in order to be
able to support all this work we need to
make sure we have enough people who are
trained interested skilled you know
wanting to work in these spaces and that
it that cuts across both spaces so the
alternative energy sort of new
technologies as well as really
maximizing the traditional ones so for
example in 2010 we started we began
what's now a national model for shale
net which is a stackable credential wing
program hard for me to say
stackable credentialing program
basically they help more people be able
to do some of those natural gas
extraction jobs that's resulted in over
5,000 people being trained and it's been
expanded across the country that's one
aspect but then we also have done
research and looking at where we have a
mismatch and some of our degree programs
to where if some of the need is and
speaking now with educators and higher
education institutions about how we can
be working to make sure that we've got
basically the people that we need to be
able to move these things forward so
that's an advantage a lot of other
places in the region are now I'm sorry
across the country are now trying to
emulate well the work we've been doing
here on that way one of the challenges
facing emerging technologies in the
startup area is is funding how would you
characterize the climate in Pittsburgh
for funding early-stage energy companies
particularly with regards to you know
strategic companies in the area not
necessarily traditional angels and VCs
how would you characterize the the
funding landscape for uh well energy
startups having personally raised money
in Pittsburgh not for energy companies
like talking about
as far as you know it's a large user of
energy we are actively an investor in
those sorts of activities and so what
I'd say is is that it's a good place to
be because one of the things I've
noticed about Pittsburgh which is
different than Silicon Valley things
like that is is that there is a really
tight network it's it's pretty easy
within a couple people you can get
connected to most anyone in Pittsburgh
and people are really I've never seen
anything like it
we're really actively wanting to help
people out and so you know we have
relationship to all universities and so
people that have touches to the rates to
the universities can touch us you know
there's numbers of startups that are
energy related that we have
conversations with right now so how does
givest row do that crap how do you do
that on a continuing ongoing basis magic
well a couple things one is is that you
know we try to stay in touch with the
universities there's also through the
different kinds of you know startup
programs like the innovation works the
accelerators awful a valpha gear you
know we have relations for those people
a lot of the tech transfer people within
the universities we have relationships
with so yes we have an ongoing
conversation about what we're interested
in what we're trying to do it's a way
for them to say hey you know I have this
company may want to talk to idea this
professor and this idea or here's this
startup and then also having personally
been the startup community I get calls
from people I know hey girl you know
I've got to talk to these guys and so I
would say that it's a great place to get
started because there is a lot of a
network that you can tap into that can
also extend beyond just Pittsburgh -
thank you for the iw and Alpha lab alpha
left ear plugs appreciate it
I think it's good I would agree but I
know and and speaking for 30-odd energy
companies that that that we've supported
and invested in over the last six or
seven years I think we would all agree
that it could be better there's been a
significant growth and the know
of investments that are made in energy
companies over the last four to five
years some of that was accelerated or
energized by commitment from the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania but there
still is lacking I think here a fuller
connection to the importance of the
value of these energy startups they're
here though and for a variety of reasons
one career you mentioned is that this is
probably the most collaborative
innovation city and region in the world
you're literally are one or two phone
calls away from somebody who may in
another place feel like they have a
competitive relationship with you and
they will they will support you there
are test beds for just about any type of
research that you might need to do or if
you're working on product validation or
development you don't have to go too far
to find cadastro or a corporate partner
that can help you and is carly mentioned
we've got a national lab a stone's throw
away and so the access that you have to
this a do-e national ambition I should
mention so the access to that these
energy startups have to them is an
access that they would not be able to
get anywhere else
I would I would like to add that that
the access the resources in the
collaboration is there but the capital
isn't in and technically you know and
just being honest the the venture the
venture ecosystem here should just step
up and start investing more dollars in
the energy space you know it's heavy
heavy heavy meds I'm here in bio biotech
and I understand ibly so but in order to
really make though I think the region as
strong as we can more dollars needs to
be going towards energy related in
and innovative technologies especially
what's coming out of pit and CMU that
that needs to happen and while there are
lots of larger companies like Co vestro
that are doing sort of the work
themselves to try to be supportive
one thing that Anna and Jeff and I and
others have been looking into is whether
or not there is a need or a value to
have something more structured so
corporate venture capital group's you
know entities sort of that body where
people and different companies buy into
sort of committing dollars and talents
and mentorship and those kinds of
opportunities exists in other regions
and so there could really be an
opportunity here to do something more
organized and formal this next question
should be a lively one this is from the
audience why won't the accd withdraw
support for the ethane cracker facility
when it will double regional carbon
emissions undoing the climate benefits
of current innovations Industrial
Development is always complicated is one
way to put it as we mentioned earlier
there's been a commitment to fuel
diversity and having a variety of
different resources contribute to our
energy mix and in order to do so the
caveat to that is to do it right to do
it as well as possible to take into
consideration the environmental impacts
and make sure that we're doing
everything we can to offset them so from
the Allegheny conferences role there
we've been a supporter of sustainable
shale development standards there's a
bunch of best practices and leading
thought on how to do this as well as
possible we've encouraged shale and
they've been partners all along in
taking the best-in-class approach to
this project does that mean that there
will be zero impacts no of course there
will be but the research and the
assessment as to how the the other
values the other benefits that this
brings to the region to workers
residents here as well as to our natural
gas resource that has a lot of methane
in it and right now it is either being
burned off or basically give it away and
that's bad because ethane has a lot of
value it's in so many of the products we
need for medical purposes to space
travel to your shampoo bottle and to
just burn that off and waste it is worse
than trying to do something with it well
and so that's been that's been the
position that there's there's a real
value to the region in in pursuing this
opportunity but that it needs to be done
in a responsible way all right next
question what is being done or can be
done to train involve more minorities in
the energy sector and in the energy
entrepreneurship arena not enough not
enough I'm encouraged in a in a few
places we've got an opportunity here in
Pittsburgh if you were here yesterday
you heard about some some concepts from
microgrids and in urban settings there
is some intention to ensure that those
micro grids ultimately are designed and
somewhat supported by those communities
it's a small thing but I I'm hoping that
that becomes a much larger thing part of
this is obviously a workforce
development challenge just across the
board part of this is an educational
issue across the board I'd like to say
that that we've got a Pittsburgh has a
fairly high energy IQ but we still are
not necessarily where we should be I
think
actually the first question that we got
from from the audience
illustrate that and we do kind of
question the impacts that energy have on
our communities and that is a sign of a
good high energy IQ but we've got to
start earlier we are an innovative
entrepreneurship as a way to communicate
opportunities in this space to younger
and younger audiences so we actually
have programs for high school-age kids
and I think we've got an opportunity
through that to boost the IQ and
hopefully encourage more and more this
is also inclusion an innovation week
here in Pittsburgh and and if we
continue to have other opportunities
like that I think we'll start to see
positive change to piggyback Jeff I
think it's true and I think it's
exposure right you know a personal story
I didn't know anything about energy tell
us about 25 or 26 it's just because in
my neighborhood and the way I grew up
you know we just said no I don't know
what a kilowatt hour was so if I'm an
elementary school or middle school or
high school and I don't know what that
means then why would I want to pursue
energy or technology or job or career
that way and it just it just makes sense
that if young people know and understand
and you can have some exposure early on
to the careers with job opportunities
that exist or and they can find their
own journey find their own way and I
think there's enough there's a lot of
advocacy groups and champions and
Pittsburgh that are doing some work I
just think you know we need to do more
of it and more collaboration more
consistently and you will see the
results we'll see the fruit fruits of
that but I think we are scratching the
surface of doing that it just needs more
and more impact
you know and I know that there's there's
a lot going on here you know I you know
Anna was was gracious enough to allow
some of our students for the without a
foundation to be on CMU's campus to
really feel the impact of
entrepreneurship startups and what it
means to attain that right because so
many students just don't know so that
was that was a beautiful thing and those
are just that just does just the
beginning of it you know and that's I
think that's what we have to go we have
to start somewhere and keep keep that
track I'm glad you mentioned inclusive
innovation week because we're kind of
overlapping events this week one of the
organizations I'm involved with up in
Hermitage has an entrepreneurship
Academy where we bring in high school
seniors from 12 local high schools four
days a week their senior year and the
mornings they go to their anchor school
and the afternoons they come to our
entrepreneurship Academy and the kids
are given a myers-briggs personality
assessment they're put together in teams
of three to four kids you have to come
up with a project by the end of their
senior year and build a working
prototype so there's a lot of Technology
and more importantly it's teaching kids
innovation and in Hermitage which is a
rural community about an hour north of
Pittsburgh I'm very excited to see the
diversity in our on our entrepreneurship
Academy we're about 40 45 percent girls
there's a lot of minorities in the in
the group as well and the kids kids
really doing well we're looking at
bringing that program to Pittsburgh were
actually in conversations with CMU in
terms of providing a area so the answer
to that question that I think we all
here know that the best performing teams
are diverse teams okay how can students
and young professionals without highly
technical backgrounds support energy
innovation and entrepreneurship and
Pittsburgh region
support it or get involved with it
this says support well I think that you
don't miss a have to have a technical
degree D to get involved with technical
type businesses because you know there's
a lot of common sense that goes into it
also I think there's an education piece
that the magic of the internet there are
so much information out there that you
can you can fairly quickly become
literate in a lot of different areas and
if you look at a number of stuff
entrepreneur startups they're not
necessarily they have technical people
work for them or work with them to solve
the problem but they may have a vision
based on looking at things and exploring
different kinds of ideas and then they
find the right technical people to help
make that reality come true so I don't
think you have to be a deeply technical
person involved at all both blue tree
and and innovation works invest in in
teams and every team has technical
wizards that are good at the science
part of it but they also have to have
other components can you speak to that a
little bit Jeff in terms of what
constitutes a well-balanced team and if
if you're not a technical wizard you
know you might be able to get really
good at marketing or finance or
something else if you could speak you've
got to be well balanced as a team and
what we continue to see is that while
there may be technical founding teams
that the the best performing ones are
the ones that recognize that despite
their expertise and electrical
engineering or material science that
alone isn't necessarily going to move
their idea and company forward they need
other skill sets
most of the energy companies that that I
work with have a very broad array of
on the team not all of the team members
have college degrees many of the key
members of those teams have transferable
experience so in the in the energy space
going back to some of the kind of
workforce related subjects from before
it's very easy to transfer experience
from perhaps one fossil technology to
another whether it's a fluid system most
most heating is still at least in my day
and the Navy didn't matter whether or
not it was nuclear energy or it was
liquid fuel that energy was used to make
water really hot turn it into steam and
then you know turn turn the propeller at
the back of the ship I mean that was
basically it
oversimplified but so there there are a
lot of transferable skills I think we
need to do a better job of helping a lot
of those individuals realize that those
skills that they have already acquired
are transferable in it and that's part
of that energy IQ piece that I think is
missing why is no one mentioned climate
change this is from a student maybe one
of your students well why is no one
mentioned climate change is a driver for
innovation and creativity I'm glad you
did whoever you are because it is right
we we respond to problems and you know
issues in the world that's where
creativity comes from and so the move to
figuring out other forms of energy
production and alternative fuels and how
we're going to store it and get it to
where it's needed and all those things
is is certainly heightened by the fact
that people perceives that there's a
real need to to figure out alternatives
I believe in climate change so I believe
in a all the above approach to energy
because in part because of that I think
and this goes beyond our administration
we have not been thinking forward enough
overall that's not a indictment on
Pittsburgh I think it's just an
indictment on our kind of national kind
of energy desires we continue to I think
miss the boat at least a little bit when
it comes to thinking about what the
energy technology is going to be for our
future but you know some of the best
work that is actually being done is
being done here and that's another thing
to be encouraged about I do think that
across the board though we are very
sensitive to you know the impacts that
even the older technologies have on you
know on our communities and we'll
continue to try to get better at that -
I think climate change is really really
really big right and sometimes I think
it's so big that people forget you know
that we can take steps in solving the
problem you know I listen to a roar sure
are say that you know we've been we've
been discussing the building emissions
or 40% fertile has 20 years and then I
heard Donna Andersen say that he hates
to work Harbin so you have these
competing interests as well as what you
know what what makes dollars and cents
you know is it is it is it a is it a
more cultural aspect that we attack
climate change or you know how do we
really truly make the make the business
case and the cultural case that's why we
need it I think if we can really marry
the two together and not have big big
private equity for
like kill it and we have great nonprofit
organizations like GBA championing and
marry the two we can solve that I think
you can you have a good chance at
solving the climate the climate climate
change but hemad if you will you know
it's so big you know and that but it's
it's uh it's trying to find a happy
medium of what what makes the most sense
there really is that two parts right
there's the production side you know it
coming where is carbon coming from and
how can we reduce that but then also on
the end user side right reducing our
energy usage increasing energy
efficiency and again we've got a lot of
the leading research and ideas and
technology for those things whether it's
building systems or transportation or
others happening here in Pittsburgh and
so the one thing we could always use
more of is probably more research
dollars and that to build off what Jeff
was saying that's one thing where as I
as a country we we still actually are
not even close to investing enough in Rd
if we wanted to actually make it
difference in some of these goals we
should be putting more dollars towards
it the comment new technologies to
existing applications is important new
technologies to existing applications
are you able to speak to new
technologies being considered by the
panelists well we we look at new to new
technologies across a couple of fronts
one is sources of energy so example
renewables so we're looking at wind
power we're looking at solar we're also
looking at the other part of the
equation which is consumption and so we
we've invested a ton of money in making
our processes more efficient so you know
we've we've come up with new ways one of
the big things we make is chlorine and
it takes a massive amount of electricity
in that and so we spent you know huge
dollars come up with technology that
could reduce that energy usage by 25
percent so I don't think kind of a will
and Jeff
we're talking about is it there's not
one size fits all in terms of solving
that energy equation there's renewable
production but also to there's more
effective and efficient use of it and I
think that you can get further down the
path in terms of a sustainable future by
attacking the problem of how
inefficiently we use energy as well we
we've invested a company's excuse me
that have platform technologies that
touch a number of energy applications
whether it's utilizing specialized
polymers to reduce the amount of water
that it takes to go down a fracking rig
reduces the amount of flow back water
that comes back up so that's you know
addressing something that's really clear
but really we don't you know we don't do
our own horns about technology like that
could be material science that helps
coat the heat exchangers and power
plants with a with a material and a
technology that is not detrimental E
impacting the environment in the process
we've got a company called like la watt
learn which is making you know a duty a
single duty cycle battery that really
does not have a brain smart so these are
technologies that are being applied to
existing processes today and then here
in Pittsburgh we also have a number of
energy efficiency technologies that are
being strapped on to smart meters that
are looking at comprehensive ways of
reducing demand today not a generation
from now and making significant impacts
in our carbon footprint and I would add
that
within 400 miles of the let's call it
Allegheny County
there's 17,000 manufacturing and
industrial plants chemicals plastics
manufacturing and fabrication plants and
all those plants so should profit from
the petrochemical and ethane production
but we're not talking about the current
innovation and technologies that could
make those companies more efficient
because a lot of more small small
companies and small businesses you know
or you know less than a hundred million
dollars in revenue in a tremendous -
statistic that that we've looked at is
you know big big huge manufacturing
companies have found a way to latch on
technologies to make their processes
more efficient companies that make less
than 100 million dollars don't and it's
like 80 percent of those companies don't
so you see this huge gap in revenue and
in production because they don't they
don't latch on innovative technologies
so that's a huge opportunity for you
know new innovation and technology
companies within this region to go and
seek out those those businesses and
those companies that that Jeff spoke of
and that Korea spoke Oh huge opportunity
Ben would like to know your opinions on
the on the carbon tax my personal
opinion is that it's the most efficient
way to create a market that would help
us have the money to actually be able to
invest in the options that can reduce
our use of carbon so you put a price on
it
that means the market can respond
without a price it means that you're
sort of hitting some companies
businesses technologies options against
each other instead of actually creating
a a level and predictable way for for
folks to engage
after hearing dawn from Blackstone last
night at the dawn who's on stage and by
the way
your sock game is strong very strong
today enough that really it is I'm
starting to change my thinking a little
bit on on that on that on the carbon
question what I would have said and I'm
about to say is that the u.s. is lagging
behind again it's the energy IQ question
lagging behind perhaps most of the EU
children for the most part have a much
better sense there where their power
comes from they know roughly where the
plant is that's probably keeping the
lights on and here I don't always know
where my energy is coming from and so if
we can't get up to some you know minimum
knowledge level about all of those
impacts it's really hard to to get
behind or to get the nation behind
factoring in all of the other things
that we should be factoring in that are
very important to to create that type of
system so you know I think that it's
going to happen but I think it's going
to continue to take a while before we
get there Jeff could you explain to the
audience what EU is for the energy IQ
well I just meant and I just met the
European Union in that case and not
energy you see yeah too many acronyms
yeah yeah that's right
okay Jeff and I also were other hats
were both on the board of the Green
Building Alliance and we had Paul Hawken
come to Pittsburgh a couple months ago
he gave a talk about a book he is
editing and it's called drawdown and
anyone interested in climate change it's
a great book he didn't write it but he
talked to a hundred of the smartest
people in the world who identified and
had been working on climate change
issues for years and he identified
hundred small things that we can do to
really reverse
climate change so I highly recommend
that to anybody who's interested this
next question is from Ben how how our
nearby university is collaborating on
energy innovation research startups what
are your opinions on how this can be
improved so a lot of the companies that
end up coming to innovation works are
going into our accelerators are coming
out of the universities here in
Pittsburgh other universities around the
country and I think that the
universities that embrace innovation and
give students who've got great ideas a
space to to to grow those ideas is a
great thing so we really benefit my
group from from those universities that
are supporting it there's a little bit
there's more than a billion dollars a
year now coming into the region in
federal research dollars and the startup
community ends up becoming a kind of
secondary beneficiary of that and so
they're able to leverage that once they
start their companies but I think that
we can always there's always room to
strengthen the connections throughout
the ecosystem so we could be doing more
with some of the larger companies that
are in the region we could be doing more
we being the startup community of
connecting and maybe even deeper into
the universities figuring out how we can
move faster this next question goes back
to the fossil fuel industry what's the
Holy Grail you see in oil and gas
technology referring to what would be
the ideal disrupter to the industry
well I think it depends because from
from a petrochemical standpoint it's
really looking at it going from those
fossil fuels to bio-based and that's a
huge challenge if that's if that you
know making that a reality would would
would be a huge step forward in this
this whole sustainability aspect of of
production of all the plastics and
polymers that we use on a day to day
basis so that would be enormous from an
energy standpoint it states the
renewables basically you're not going to
use fossil fuels anymore I mean I think
we we know that at least from a
transportation fuel standpoint we are
not going to be as dependent on fossil
fuels as we have been now there's going
to be a shift in in other areas as well
but I think it's I think it's clear that
Eevee will be the predominant
transportation technology within our
lifetimes for most applications and so I
think that is driving unintended you
know driving us away from the dependency
at least in some areas of the energy
sector on and where I've said it really
seems like energy storage technology is
what's holding us back in a lot of ways
for all kinds of applications if you can
right now a lot of our energy is just in
time delivery right that's what we need
we need it when you flip on the light
switch that has to be basically produced
it said to you and if you can get to the
point where you can store the energy
that's being produced at times when
people aren't using it the entire
equation for how we have to balance our
electric grid in particular could really
really change and that would be the
tipping point all right I think I'm
getting the hook here so I'd like to
take this opportunity to thank our panel
kuri Crookston from Co vestro will Allen
from nascent group Jeff McDaniel from
innovation work
Buckwald from Allegheny Conference if we
could please give them a big hand
and Anna who's up next so first let's
take a minute and thank our panel this
morning thank you so much panelist
so our guest speaker is here for 11:30
Dave Danielson we just need a minute to
get him miked up so I'm gonna give you
all about a 5-minute break and we'll
start back up again so just five minutes
don't go anywhere
yeah
it's in my bag and these mics are on
good afternoon everyone we're gonna get
started if you'll take your seats we're
gonna get ready for our next session
so our keynotes before lunch today
is Dave Danielson he is here from
breakthrough energy ventures and the
director for the Scott Institute for
energy innovation dr. J Whittaker is
going to provide us with an introduction
hello welcome back to second day of
energy week I was out this morning
teaching class so I missed up until now
so I hope all has been going well I'm
here to introduce actually a friend of
mine who I've known for some time when
he first took over as a program manager
in the early days the founding days in
fact of arpa-e I emailed him to ask him
a random question thinking there's no
way I was gonna get a response this was
2009 they had thousands and thousands of
applications to to get started with
arpa-e and email me back within minutes
asking me questions and as such that
started a long-term communication loop
that we've had for over a decade now
it's been lovely she currently now is a
managing director for science and
breakthrough energy ventures he also
serves as a Precourt energy scholar at
Stanford he's considered a global expert
in the development of next-generation
clean technologies and the creation of
new R&D organization models for
high-impact clean innovation so he also
works at beyond arpa-e he also is
assistant secretary of energy efficiency
and renewable energy EERE where he led
the world's largest government clean
energy innovation funding organization
before joining de r and arpa-e
Danielson was sorry before joining URI
he was also employee number one as I
mentioned arpa-e and has been you know
impactful in this field in many
different ways so without further ado
dating
okay well good afternoon how's everybody
doing good all right I'm really excited
to be here today Jay thanks so much for
that kind introduction you know this is
the second time I've been out here in
just two or three months you know and
one thing I wanted to compliment Jay you
and and I you know see you at Carnegie
Mellon and the whole ecosystem out here
is I'd say you know ten years ago when I
was working in in this face of kind of
energy
clean tech climate tech you know it
might not have been really obvious to me
to come up to Carnegie Mellon and spend
a lot of time but I can say you know
with all the great work that this
community is done to really build the
ecosystem out here now for me you know
Carnegie Mellon is like a key
destination you know I'd say there are
four or five places that I want to hit
every two or three months and this is
one of them and so I really want to
compliment you for what you've achieved
and so I'm here today really to tell you
about about something new that I'm a
part of it's called breakthrough energy
ventures it's a new fund that's
investing in transformative energy
climate tech startups with a really kind
of a big impact Longview and you know
I'd say most importantly what I want to
do is kind of introduce you to break
their energy ventures who we are where
we are what we're all about but probably
equally importantly I want to tell you
about some of the areas that that early
on in our getting up and running we've
been up and running for a little about a
year are some areas investment thesis
areas some areas where we want to really
back great entrepreneurs and innovators
to get after some of these big big
problems in energy and and in greenhouse
gas emissions reduction and I think the
one thing you know I got a chance to
come here three or four months ago as
part of a tour that myself and a number
of my colleagues did around the country
where we we engaged with with more than
130 top innovation organizations all
around the world and one thing I really
want to kind of emphasize in terms of
what breakthrough is all about and in
terms of the partnership that we can
form is when you know we had that you
know big clean tech investment boom many
of you will remember about it
they kind of had a bit of a crash and
you know we're coming back out of that
right now in a pretty exciting way but
one thing I've noticed is I think that
people were encouraged during those
leaner years you know a couple three a
few leaner years in there where there
wasn't a lot of venture investment in
the space to think a little smaller and
so if there's one thing I want you to
take away from my talk today is that in
my mind in terms of working with us it's
time to think big again and so I want to
tell you about some of the problems that
we're really interested in but most
importantly we want you know I know many
of you have really big ideas and often
you can't get support for those ideas
those are the ideas that that we want to
talk to you about a breakthrough
so to tee this up you know the way we
view this is that energy and climate are
the defining challenge of our time you
know they're about on the order of seven
billion people on earth today and
interestingly almost six billion of
those people are in less developed
countries countries that aren't they
don't have very high GDP that aren't
using a lot of energy by 2050 the UN
projects that will have closer to ten
million people on this planet and all of
those two billion people we're going to
add are going to be people in those less
developed countries and so we've got
about 33% more people coming on board
between now and 2050 and if you look at
the aspirations of those people to get
to kind of Human Development Index that
that's that's up around what we see in
more developed countries they're gonna
have to increase their their energy
services that they're consuming on a per
capita basis by at least five times so
we have 33% more people all of those in
these less developed countries all those
people are looking for a 5x increase in
the amount of of energy services and and
other resource services that they are
that they want to consume to live a life
that's I think that's at a par in terms
of quality of life with what many folks
in more developed countries have at the
same time our greatest scientists are
telling us well we need to be providing
so many more resources over the next 30
years the best scientists in the world
have made it clear to us now that we
need to reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions by at least 80 percent or 5x
over the next just over the next thirty
years going to 2050 so to me this is our
defining challenge
we've got to provide a lot more
resources and services to people so we
can get the global middle class growing
and create human wellbeing at the same
time we've got a 5x challenge in terms
of reducing our emissions so this is a
huge challenge a huge opportunity and
the way I like to frame this up is in
the context of a 70 Giga ton per year of
greenhouse gas emissions gap and so if
you look at just about where we are
today we're at about 50 Giga tons per
year of emissions and if you look at all
of the projections for where we might go
the middle case projection which i think
is a little bit unoptimized ik is at
about 80 and so if you look at that
future where we may be headed versus
where we need to go to there's a 70 Giga
ton gap which is pretty significant and
the way that we view this is that we're
quite optimistic there are a lot of
great technologies that are now in the
market are coming down in costs we have
solar wind that electric vehicles LEDs
we've got a lot of solutions that are
getting into the market and rapidly
penetrating it so there's a lot of great
work that needs to be done in
accelerating the deployment of
technologies that we already have today
but we also see and I say especially
Bill Gates who is really behind
breakthrough energy ventures there's a
breakthrough energy technology gap where
there are a number of sectors and areas
where we don't have good technologies
yet in the market or yet developed and
that there's a huge need and opportunity
for us to both scale up what we have
today but we've also got to invest in
the R&D and building the disruptive
startups that are going to deliver
solutions in the next 10 15 20 years in
areas where we don't have solutions
today and that's really what motivated
Bill Gates to in 2015 going into the
cop21 Paris agreement and the months
ahead of that he reached out and engaged
with the leaders of all the major
economies and he said you know what we
need to solve this breakthrough energy
technology gap and he challenged them to
double their energy R&D over the next
five years across all the major
economies and on his side of the table
he said if you're willing to double your
investments I'm willing to double down
on mine and I'm going to recruit
some of the most influential
entrepreneurs and investors who are
represented of the most high net-worth
individuals on the planet to do it with
me and that resulted in what actually
going back the there was an announcement
a big announcement of a new initiative
that came out of that conversation on
the government side is called mission
innovation which was a commitment by all
the major economies to double their
energy R&D over five years where I'd say
the gross majority of all those
companies by all those countries by the
way are on a path to doubling and then
on the private side Bill Gates recruited
a couple dozen key individuals to join
him in what was called a breakthrough
Energy Coalition who are committing to
double down in quotes double down on
their investments on the private side to
help support the creation of new
startups in the area and then over the
course that was in 2015 the end of 2015
was was cop and mission innovation
breakthrough Energy Coalition the course
of 2016
bill reached out to the key people in
his network who he knew really cared
about this problem and over the course
of that year recruited 20 of these
visionary leaders from all around the
world to join him in creating a billion
dollar fund that would invest in these
startups in these transformative
greenhouse gas emissions reducing
financially viable new startups and so
what's exciting to me is that you not
only have people like Jeff Bezos Vinodh
Khosla Michael Bloomberg John doar but
you also have people from all over the
world you've got hostile partner from
Germany the founder of SA P you've got
Mukesh Ambani the wealthiest man in
India you've got Jack Ma from China and
a number of others so this is truly a
global group and I actually did the
rough calculation yesterday this group
represents on the order of 500 billion
dollars of net worth and so these kind
of people taking this problem seriously
and putting real money into it is a big
deal and and so breakthrough energy
ventures was launched at the beginning
of 2017 with a led by these investors
and there are a few things are a little
different about what we're doing
what's been done in the past the the
first I'd say is this group the this
group of very influential folks who can
get things done that need to get done
and who have the capital to to push
successful companies forward but but
separate from that we've done a few
other things differently with this fund
it's a as many of you know energy
resource innovation climate innovation
takes time so this isn't a ten year fund
like we're used to in venture capital
this is a 20 year fund so we have the
ability to build companies over the long
haul to build incredibly valuable
companies we're not constrained by that
that kind of short window that I think
is hurt hurt the venture industry as it
relates to clean tech you know in the
1.0 boom we're also taking a different
approach in terms of team building we
have about 20 people on board now who
have a very broad spectrum of expertise
all the way from investors and
entrepreneurs and company builders to
people who have government experience
policy experienced people who are
scientists and technologists and
engineers and folks from industry and so
we have a very different view in terms
of assessing companies and in terms of
helping those companies succeed when
they go forward I'd say the most
significant element of this fund is that
it is exclusively focused on backing
companies that are working on solutions
that have entitlement who have the
possibility to have a huge impact on
greenhouse gas emissions and the the
filter or the the bogie that we're
putting out there is that we're
interested in companies that are
developing solutions or sets of
solutions that if fully deployed in 2050
could have at least half a Giga ton of
impact on reducing greenhouse gas
emissions and that's about 1% of today's
of today's emissions and so from our
perspective that's the the opportunity
to challenge the partnership that we
want to put forward to you and other
innovators all around the world is what
are those half Giga ton impact problems
and what are your ideas to build great
companies around those and we call this
the half Giga ton year challenge and so
what you just kind of abstract what's
half a Giga ton right and so I wanted to
kind of frame it up for you
half a Giga ton is about 250 gigawatts
of wind or solar replacing Hall or about
50 billion gallons per year of zero
carbon transport fuels like like second
generation biofuels so this kind of
frames up how big we're talking here and
to put that in comparison 2016 over the
history of mankind we had deployed about
500 gigawatts of wind power about twice
that half gig at time and then if you
look at how you know the 50 million
gallons is about a third of all of us
gasoline demand today so you know a half
a Giga ton win is is a really just put
it in perspective is that really it's a
high bar there aren't a huge number of
problems that if you solve them are half
Giga ton kind of problems but those are
the problems we're interested in and in
terms of this 70 Giga ton per year gap I
wanted to also frame up the economic
opportunity and I was trying to think of
a good comparison about you know how
many large companies are likely to be
formed if we succeed in this 70 Giga ton
gap closing and so I looked at
ExxonMobil if you look at their amount
of production of fossil fuels it was
about 0.6 around 1/2 a Giga ton per year
last year and that company's worth about
80 billion dollars and so if you take
about just say 70 Giga tons so there's
140 you're 70 divided by 0.5 half a Giga
ton more than a hundred Exxon Mobil kind
of economic opportunities are on the
table out to 2050 so this is a big huge
opportunity so that's why we think we
can create a huge impact but also create
huge companies by doing what we're
looking to do a breakthrough energy
ventures so I wanted to frame it up you
know that we were trying to think a
little bit differently you know there
there were some successes but a lot of
failures in clean tech 1.0 so we've been
trying to think hard about how are we
going to do things differently you know
other than a multidisciplinary team
amazing set of backers and a 20-year
window those are all good start but we
also wanted to think a little bit
differently and really get deep into
what we see is the mega trends that are
going to be really driving the next kind
of 10 20 30 years as it relates to
energy and climate so the first is that
we are encouraged and we're seeing
motion action progress on the on the
part of global governance
taking action on climate things are
moving in the right direction I said
they're moving slowly but they're moving
in the right direction but it's a more
importantly there are what we see is
more inevitable megatrends that we want
to be aware of and we want to be
investing around the first is what I
would say is very low cost
you know ultra low-cost intermittent of
wind and solar so when I was a when I
was at the Department of Energy we were
you know paying the SunShot grand
challenge to try to get solar to a buck
a watt which is on the order of five or
six cents per kilowatt hour everyone
thought was crazy now we're seeing in
the market we're seeing three four cents
per kilowatt hour solar projects we're
seeing you know two cents and below
projects being done for wind and so you
you can't get those kind of electricity
prices at scale in many places so this
is disruptive this is a transformation
and our analysis says it's going to
continue to come down the other one is
lithium-ion battery cost reductions and
vehicle electrification it's been
shocking how quickly we've seen that
lithium-ion battery pack cost go from
more than a thousand dollars per
kilowatt hour when I started the
Department of Energy to now were you
know approaching a hundred right and so
it's phenomenal progress and when we do
our analysis and we look at where it can
go we think and go a lot lower so we're
very bullish about where lithium-ion
batteries and where electric vehicle
deployment is going the shale boom and
cheap gas so this has been a revolution
just in the last few years here in North
America where we've got $3 per mm BTU
gas we've got a lot of it available so
you know that's a mega trend that we
need to be aware of investing around
looking for opportunities at the same
time the horizontal drilling and multi
zonal stimulation technology that's been
developed there has been on its own kind
of exponential learning curve and that's
something that we're paying a lot of
attention to distributed and modular
everything and the Internet of Things so
one of the big challenges that I saw in
clean tech 1.0 is when you had to go
build these really big plants and you
know let's say a biofuels plant you put
a bunch of money a new company you do
the science you do the engineering it
looks like it works then you go build a
pilot then you go build a demo then you
build a first commercial and none of
those are profitable
you know that is a lot of risk to take
on and so one thing that we're
particularly interested in is investing
in distributed modular technologies
where you can get in the market with and
actually be profitable and get into kind
of niche first markets with modular
smaller technologies as opposed to
having to bite off that multi hundred
million dollar bet before you have any
proof or any or any sort of de-risking
and then in terms of with advanced you
know information communication
technologies now we can control a lot of
these more smaller modular things in a
much more efficient way
generally speaking exponential
technologies obviously CMU is a big part
of this revolution but you know there
are a number of areas where you'd say
five years ago or today we're just not
there you know you know we'd love to be
able to to ferment you know wood into
this this fuel or high value molecule
but you know the technology is 10x away
but now that you've got synthetic
biology and and the exponential curves
of DNA synthesis and sequencing for
example those are in your sights if you
know where those technologies are going
right so we're paying a lot of attention
to exponential technologies very
importantly and this relates a lot to
our our investors is is the end the
nature of the problem this is a global
challenge right a lot of most of the
growth is going to be in China India
Africa Indonesia and so we're very much
setting ourselves up to be aware of and
investing around where the growth is
both investing in companies in North
America and Europe that will deploy and
emerging economies and going and finding
boots on the ground companies in those
geographies and backing them and then
finally urbanization and so what we're
seeing is with the rapid move towards
urbanization we're much more interested
in solutions that are going to solve
urban problems than problems that are
more of a rural nature and so you can
check out our website there's an eye
chart but we started out when we
launched with this landscape of
innovation it's got 55 technical quests
or Grand Challenges but since this was
released you know basically when we were
launched we've done a lot of work
applying these megatrends looking at the
half Gigaton opportunities to identify a
few thesis investment areas that we're
really interested in and i'm going to
talk to you about
those they're by no means comprehensive
you may have ideas in other areas if you
got a half a Giga ton entitlement you've
got a real business we want to talk and
so we're really we have sub teams you
have teams around these five sectors
each of which have very significant
emissions electricity power
transportation agriculture manufacturing
and buildings and I'm going to talk
about examples of things that were very
interested in each of those areas except
for buildings and but we are still very
interested in buildings just a matter of
just the time I have today so in
electricity as I said before we're
really one of the big mega trends that
we are we are investing around that we
believe in we've analyzed is this ultra
low-cost renewable electricity again
we're seeing two three cents per
kilowatt hour wind and solar PBA's we
are being told that people expect to see
some of the the first one cent per
kilowatt hour BPA's and wind in North
America coming up soon and you know we
it's slowing but we see this continuing
to move so what are the opportunities
and challenges that you get when you
can't when you are in a world awash in 1
2 3 cent per kilowatt hour but
intermittent or a low capacity factor
wind and solar and so one of the areas
that we're really interested in is in
ultra long duration grid storage so this
is as you're getting higher and higher
penetrations of wind and solar you know
what are the challenges you get is that
these are bidding into the market when
they're available right and so
essentially they bid in at zero because
they have no marginal cost no fuel costs
and so as you bid in more and more you
where you're you know if you're a solar
plant and you're bidding in the middle
of the day the more and more solar there
is the lower the price is getting
there's a bit of a falling knife problem
I think that when you get to higher and
higher penetrations of wind and solar
the price that you're gonna get paid is
getting lower and lower and lower and
you're kind of chasing that cost curve
and so you need other technologies in
our view like grid storage to help
ameliorate the the issues that you face
around getting really high penetrations
of wind and solar that you're going to
need to dramatically decarbonize the
grid and so lithium ion is going coming
down so fast yeah
we've done a lot of analysis Jays done a
lot of analysis in this area but you
know when we talked to experts they say
10 years from now they wouldn't be
shocked if a fully installed grid
storage plant with lithium ion is $150
per kilowatt hour and they definitely
wouldn't completely bet against it being
at $100 per kilowatt hour and we're more
like at about $500 per kilowatt hour
today and so you know that is low enough
to cover multiple hours right so let's
say five six seven eight hours that you
might need to provide some buffering of
renewable power provide some firming and
so I'd say on one hand were very
interested in any technology solution
that can get below that about $100 per
kilowatt hour any solutions that come to
us that are higher than that we think
it's probably a a big gamble in terms of
where we see with the amaya ongoing so
that's kind of a floor so it we're
interested in things that are below $100
per kilowatt hour that have that
entitlement 5 to 10 years from now but
I'd say something that we aren't seeing
a lot of people think about that we're
thinking about and this is a bit of a
noisy chart but you know you can see
lithium ion and the blue there where we
think this is a the duration of storage
versus the installed cost of capital
cost upfront $1 per kilowatt hour and
when you get to higher and higher
penetrations a big opportunity we see
are kind of two use cases that would be
in the like hundreds to thousands of
hours not just you know five to ten
hours but what that means is that these
are these applications you know are
needed let's say for let's say if you
had a base load wind plant right a wind
plant they could have this one cent per
kilowatt hour but be selling it at
prices that it could get in terms like a
base load asset but in order to do that
you need something that's on the order
of $20 per kilowatt hour and then when
you get to really high penetrations of
renewables in certain geographies 7080
plus which we see going down a future
and where RPS is are headed in some US
states and and and place like Germany
are moving in that direction that you
actually have this seasonal imbalance
right like the the amount of Sun that
you get on an average day in Germany at
higher
latitudes for example is very different
in the winter than it is in the summer
so you need to find ways to buffer
energy over over months you know over a
thousand hours and so the when you're
looking at the kind of base load
renewables case you need about something
like twenty cycles a year not a daily
cycle but something like 20 deep cycles
a year and you need to get down to about
like I said $20 per kilowatt or if you
want to do that seasonal you need to get
into the realm of like $1 per kilowatt
hour and so when we've been out talking
to the community this is a use case that
a lot of people hadn't thought of and
basically what it means is there are an
extremely limited set of materials that
are cheap enough to even go $20 peel-out
hour or $1.00 per kilowatt hour and so
you end up having to try to figure out
here's the innovators challenge how do I
take sulfur how do I take super low cost
metals how do I take water how do I take
air how do I use these kind of very low
cost materials and make a storage system
that can be at that kind of cost and
well it's also interesting because it
really relieves a lot of the constraints
the typical you know energy storage in
this case looking at like a battery or a
flow battery looking technology has you
can go way low or power and you only
need to do much limited numbers of
cycles of one cycle a year 20 cycles
year as opposed to 300 cycles a year
which is what you would need with a
daily kind of application so this is a
problem we're very interested in we're
interested engaging with innovators who
have big big ideas at that $20 per
kilowatt hour or even that dollar per
kilowatt hour cost point at the same
time you know we don't believe that
storage is the panacea right so you're
gonna need in addition to a lot of
renewables that wind and good amounts of
very low cost storage you're gonna need
other dispatchable scalable zero
greenhouse gas electricity sources so
we're looking at nuclear we're looking
at CCS but in terms of the megatrends I
talked to you about one area that I am
particularly interested in we're
particularly in turmoil and so you know
geothermal has been really niche right
it's like a couple gigawatts it's you
know 1% or less of North American
electricity and if you look at most
projections almost all projections it's
there for the next 3040 years out to
2050 but when you look at when you look
at the shale boom
right there were projections at do-e of
where natural gas production would go
and when shale came in it diverged
exponentially and so we think there's a
really interesting intersectional
opportunity between the introduction the
use of you know for the first time
no-one's ever done a horizontal well in
the history of geothermal to introduce
horizontal drilling and multi zonal
fracturing technology stimulation
technology from the oil and gas industry
that's moving on an exponential curve
into the geothermal space and we're
working with some innovators in this
area we actually think this there's a
real shot that this could be a
game-changer that rides that shale gas
shale technology learning curve in terms
of transportation big you know actually
interesting is about 15 percent of
global greenhouse gas emissions which is
kind of low as a sector but that's gonna
go up like crazy as the rest of the
world adopts automotive automobiles
everyone starts buying cars all around
the world and so we've done a lot of
analysis here as I mentioned we're quite
bullish in our kind of internal analysis
on the rate of deployment of electrified
vehicles and so we tend to agree more
with these these kind of higher
projections here that at about 2030 gets
you to about 20 million new evie sales
light duty vehicle sales per year and so
what we started thinking about is well
you know let's not think too near-term
you know there are definitely challenges
for this industry in the near term there
are a lot of companies getting after
those but in terms of you know what are
the things that could slow this down
right in five years 10 years 15 years
what are the things that when you do
your analysis and you think forward
could turn this exponential into a into
and do an up-and-down or a long flat
flat part and so we've been looking at
both downstream so you know what kind of
charging infrastructure what kind of
charging rates are people going to need
to get like to get all those different
segments of people be willing to adopt
V's what kind of what kind of what kind
of a range are you gonna need you know
increasing the range increasing the
charging rate but then the other thing
we look at is upstream and so when an
industry is moving this fast it can
often be limited by the availability
of the fundamental materials that go
into the thing and so we've identified
both cobalt and lithium as two essential
elements that that could end up being a
bottleneck for the growth of this
industry and so to look at just one of
those rights which I say is the more
severe is cobalt if you look at a
projection where you're at about 20
million EVs per year in that 2030 time
frame it's pretty shocking what happens
in terms of cobalt demand it goes from
this kind of $100 per kiloton level
that's been reasonably flat for a number
of years and to up to 400 or more
kilotons per year of demand and so any
of you that are familiar with with kind
of mineral or mining or or metals kind
of industries a 4x over 10 years or so
is huge you know it's it's really hard
to deal with and particularly
interesting as we've dug in is almost
all of the supply up to that up to now
up to about the hundred kilotons has
been as a byproduct of other mining so
you got big copper mines you got big
nickel mines and they just kind of
Slough this stuff off and sell it as a
co-product but as the demand for cobalt
grows like crazy and the demand for
copper and nickel does not go nearly as
fast it's no longer enough just to get
the the Co production of the cobalt from
those so for the first time in history
over the next number of years we're
gonna have to go invent the technologies
and go out and and have businesses go
find cobalt driven resources and find
ways to cost-effectively extract them so
this is an area that we're looking at
and are very interested in but as
bullish as we are in electrification
when you look at things like air
transportation or international and
coastal shipping which are each well
over half a Giga ton of emissions today
electrification is not happening for
these you know even when you're very
bullish about electric aviation
short-haul at work when you're bullish
about you know long-haul trucking
electrification in which we think is is
kind of a you know it's a it's a
middle-of-the-road kind of proposition
these are not going to be electrified so
what are we going to do to get after
these applications these emissions and
that is where we see the need for
cost-effective low greenhouse gas
emissions liquid fuels and the two areas
the way that we're thinking about
is that it if you really want these to
be carbon neutral greenhouse gas neutral
you've got to take co2 out of the air
and put it back in it's a cycle right
and so the two ways that we see that you
can do that is biofuels so we're taking
a very serious look basically there was
a lot of carnage as we all know in the
in the recent kind of biofuels wave for
second generation biofuels like
cellulose and biofuels a lot of progress
but they didn't quite get that and so
we're taking a fresh look at that and
seeing are there ways that we can put
together the puzzle pieces of the really
amazing technology that was developed in
various parts of the supply chain and
put those together in creative ways and
also perhaps leverage the latest
breakthroughs in synthetic biology to
deliver a biofuel company that can
actually deliver at cost at scale and
you know we've also been looking
seriously at co2 other co2 to fuels
technologies and so we're very
interested in carbon capture and
conversion to fuels and in the long run
if you want that to be carbon neutral
you have to be looking at air capture
and so we're looking quite seriously at
air capture as an important long term
part of the equation in terms of liquid
fuels as well one thing that is it has
been really fun for me is I'd say
probably most of us in the room are
would consider ourselves more energy
nerds than AG nerds I would guess right
yeah it's an energy conference but when
I went from the partment of energy to
breakthrough energy from an energy
mission to a greenhouse gas focused
mission the one big new area that that I
was introduced to is really the food and
a gary a-- which is a quarter of global
emissions and the three game-changers
that we really are focused on and that
are the big contributors to emissions in
this space are the provision of animal
protein which and these are these are
these don't add up
they overlap a little bit just to for
the the math folks out there is that
animal protein is a seven Giga ton per
year they matter it's huge and I'll tell
you a little bit more about that but
two-thirds of that comes from just the
existence of cows so cows are a huge
part of the problem here that we're
looking at food waste it's a huge
challenge that
was shocked to learn is basically the
size the food waste emissions are the
equivalent or they exceed the emissions
of the country of China this is a huge
problem and then nitrogen fixation this
is basically fertilizer right you know
fertilizer for for agriculture both in
terms of the energy and missions it
takes to make ammonia which is about 1%
of global ghts and then the other part
is when you don't use the the ammonia
very efficiently that turns into n2 or
nitrogen oxide which is a really potent
greenhouse gas as well which is you know
those are about 50/50 in terms of impact
of that sector so we're very interested
in looking at you know this is an
exponential technology domain on the
nitrogen fixation side focusing maybe
more on the on the field we see a lot of
opportunities and a lot of great ideas
in the area of applying kind of
synthetic biology and microbiome to
nitrogen fixation you know there are a
very limited set of plants that could
actually fix their own nitrogen but
people haven't been able to port those
traits over to major crops like corn or
others and so we're excited about
looking at a number of companies that
are trying to tackle this issue of of
either dramatically improving the
utilization efficiency of fertilizer or
even a big vision of completely
eliminating the need for fertilizer by
pulling nitrogen straight out of the air
in terms of food waste I'll admit this
is a tough space this is a very
disaggregated space so it goes all the
way from losing crops in the field you
know where people have creative ideas
around around a perfect produce you know
like markets for carrots with two legs
all the way down to you know good
cooling solutions and transport
solutions or or inhibitors for ripening
or rotting all the way down to
innovations that would involve which the
worst place to waste food is when it's
right on your plate because you've
already invested so much in getting it
there and so ideas around like
innovative delivery models or other
models are all being considered there
but I'd say we're a little bit early and
are thinking there would be really open
to your creative and big idea
but I say the biggest opportunity we're
pursuing right now is in this low gh
g-protein area and so two-thirds of this
is the cow about half of that cow
emission comes from the whole supply
chain of just keeping that cow alive and
growing and the other half is from an
enteric fermentation so this is the the
burping of methane and so we're looking
seriously at innovative ideas for
addressing you know the methane
emissions so there microbiome approaches
that instead of emitting methane would
allow a methane conversion in the gut
that's an interesting area to look at
the other is just to completely
eliminate the cow the other half of the
emissions and so we're looking seriously
at opportunities to provide at scale
you know palatable you know solutions
for food that would have much lower
greenhouse gas so there are ideas around
using plant-based materials and then
adding in small amounts of of kind of
specialty materials like heme like
impossible foods you may know about it
as a has a burger that is plant-based
but actually tastes like a real burger
because it introduces these heme or
blood like additives at very small
percentages and then you've got
companies out there who are actually
taking mammalian cells and culturing
them in the lab and have a vision of
actually making you your whole steak
without the cow turns my stomach a
little bit right now but I think it's
very interesting it could have a huge
impact and then you know I think those
are some of the areas we think are a
really big opportunity but another thing
that was really new to me coming to this
is that you know when you look at all
the emissions from the cow half is from
beef you know which half is ground beef
and the rest is kind of different forms
of beef the other half is dairy and so
if we can find really innovative ways to
create dairy either like use
fermentation or other approaches to take
plant-based molecules and makes things
that are the functional equivalent of
milk or if we can develop other kind of
milk substitutes that are really
preferable or palatable people that
would have a huge impact on the space as
well so I think hopefully a number of
problems that that are
new to you but these are areas that we'd
love to engage with innovators on
and then the final sector I wanted to
talk about is the what I think is the
hardest sector and this is the industry
sector this is making stuff at scale and
and so I consider that you know there
aren't a lot of really great scalable
ideas out there for these sectors and
this represents a third of global
emissions and I think there's I think
there's relatively less attention paid
by entrepreneurs and innovators in this
sector than there needs to be and we'd
really love to engage with people in
this area and the three big problems
that I'd say we it would are most
interested in is steel production which
is between two and three Giga tons
emissions cement production - and
ammonia production which is a key part
of the fertilizer emissions in the case
of of steel you know it's really coming
from the coal that's being used to turn
iron iron ore or an oxide into iron and
so we think they're exciting
opportunities you know some of the best
ideas out there or potentially using
finding ways to make really cheap
hydrogen with no greenhouse gas
emissions and then using that to convert
the the iron ore instead of coal so and
so no emissions I'll talk about another
another angle in just a second and
cement is a really tough one and I say
we're like steel we're not seeing a lot
of really big ideas coming out of top
innovators in these areas a few but here
the real challenge is the Portland
cement you know like only order of ten
percent of what goes into concrete is
incredibly emission intensive and
basically you take calcium carbonate
like chalk and you have to heat it up to
make calcium oxide and that not only
requires energy heat which about half
the emissions but you're also in that
chemical version making a lot of co2 and
so you know innovative ways to reduce
the amount of Portland cement that's
needed completely new approaches to
cement alternatives to cement wood based
construction and other kinds of things
are all things that we're very
interested in then in ammonia we see
some you know I think almost all the
emissions for ammonia are from making
hydrogen from
gasps so again I think a game-changer
there would be if we could find ways to
make hydrogen we think you know if it's
$1 to $2 per kilogram you change the
world and so these are all areas we're
very interested in the last thing I
wanted to talk about is something that
actually Jay and I are working together
on and that I'm hopeful breakthrough
will we'll be partnering with with
Carnegie Mellon on to figure out whether
there might be a big opportunity here
and so generally speaking I'd say you
know the hardest sector industry to
decarbonize bridging it to a sector that
many are very optimistic will be
decarbonize more rapidly and more
efficiently and even in a more ready way
the power sector so how do we bridge
electricity to the industry sector so
electrifying industrial production and
more specifically how do we take
advantage there's kind of a new idea
we'd love to
I'd love to engage with top innovators
out there on and JE and I would love to
do that with you is how do we take this
1 to 2 cent per kilowatt hour
intermittent renewable electricity low
capacity factor electricity that we were
seeing come on in larger larger scale
and more and more places and how do we
bridge that to make zero greenhouse gas
emission stuff how do we bridge that to
make steel hydrogen ammonia if we could
do that in a cost-effective manner and
that power is really cheap which makes
it really possible
especially using the the most promising
platform I see is electrochemistry
things like an electrolyzer electrolysis
getting the big technology challenge an
opportunity here is that that people
haven't really thought about using
renewable intermittent low capacity
factor energy to directly power
industrial processes and so the big
difference here is you'd have a factory
you'd have a plant that would only be
able to operate 40 percent of the time
50 percent of the time 25 percent of the
time and so you have to think in a
completely new way about dramatically
reducing the capital cost of these
systems because you're only using them
part of the time you're getting super
cheap energy but you're only getting a
part of the time so you've got to build
it you've got to envision a new kind of
factory that is completely different
that is dramatically lower capital cost
and so this is something that Jay and I
so with that I want to thank you for
your time I hope you got to know a
little bit about us I hope that some of
these problems are problems that you're
interested in tackling with us the
bottom line I want to put out there is
is that we are we are here to support
your big ideas and it's really about
those big half Gigaton ideas and so
we've got a lot of work to do but we've
got a good amount of capital we've got
some great investors and we think
there's a tremendous opportunity to
build some of the biggest and most
successful companies in the world that
will go help us tackle this 70 Gigaton
gap thank you so much we have time for a
couple questions okay
very good thank you fantastic thanks
again for coming and we've got a number
of questions from the audience so I'm
just going to sort of sit here and
recite some of them first one actually
is another think big point that some
folks have raised as a potential for
geoengineering instead of reducing
carbon emissions I mean which is
obviously the right fight to fight other
folks are considering injecting certain
like sulfur species or other things in
the high atmosphere to reduce the impact
of the Sun and to reduce global warming
in a different way
are you guys considering that sort of
thing at all are you more focused on
mitigating the problem through carbon
reduction yeah you know we haven't
explicitly put it off the table but I'd
say for now we are very very focused on
greenhouse gas emissions and mitigation
and so there definitely a few folks out
there including high net worth folks who
are backing some teams that are looking
at some of these geoengineering things
but say for now we're completely focused
on reducing emissions and not focusing
on geoengineering great what about what
you view infusion you know like I said I
think that zero zero greenhouse gas
emissions dispatchable generation which
in a world of high renewables
penetration you're going to need you're
going to need very low cost technologies
that are dispatchable or firm and so you
know we believe that it is absolutely
critical for us to develop some number
of solutions that are going to scale you
know to at least kind of ten ten percent
or you know fifteen percent of capacity
that can support those high of renewable
penetrations and so I'd say nuclear
fusion nuclear fission carbon capture
geothermal are all on the table but I'd
say there aren't a lot of no-brainer
you know obvious wins in that area so I
think we're gonna have to look at a lot
of a lot of different things one thing
that's interesting though is that what
they've been realizing is if you do
believe in a high or at least in
geographies that would have high
renewable intermittent renewable
penetration like wind and solar it's no
longer enough to just think of like an L
seolhui a base load plant LCOE for these
kind of dispatchable things because
they're gonna go up and down they're
gonna be operating at lower capacity
factor and so I think we're beginning to
work on some more appropriate metrics
that we should be having these kind of
plants target and so like the one thing
I would say is it like you know LCOE
base load that's not the right metric
for these dispatchable sources that we
should be targeting so someone else
asked you know this is actually a hybrid
of a couple different questions that I'm
going to put together you have to think
big right and and there is so much like
many of these solutions bridge outside
the realm of one country even right if
you really want to have it's a global
impact it's a global solution that
suggests maybe also there need to be
some global or at least nationally
cogent policy drivers to create
incentive or to create space for this
are you guys looking at ways to do that
as well you can't
maybe there's a you know not just a
technical solution that's purely
economically beneficial it may need a
nudge one way or another are you is be
evey because it's so different in its
mission gonna position itself like that
as well yeah so break their energy
ventures is is just one activity I'd say
that that these you know 21 high net
worth you know influential visionaries
are backing and so but I'd say a
breakthrough we are very focused on
building great companies and so like
we're you know everything we do is
around building those great
that may involve some some thoughtful
engagement around with policymakers
around those companies but in terms of a
brought that broader you know policy
policy analysis and potential advocacy
you know I'd say one thing we have is a
sister organization that the
breakthrough Energy Coalition which was
the thing that was announced at the
cop21 meeting from which breakthrough
energy ventures came is is now getting
very active in terms of bringing
together major companies high net worth
influential individuals and innovators
entrepreneurs to engage around the right
kind of analysis you know independent
independent analysis and engagement some
thoughtful advocacy around around what
kind of policies would allow innovation
to prosper and get into the market and
then a number of our our backers are
Twitter with their own with their own
money backing all kinds of different
policy policy efforts around the world
great it's what I expected um because
you're still plugged in know there's
there is some inside baseball which
could be helpful but it I think is
really important so let's talk some
numbers some a couple other questions
they're asking things like how large
actually is this fun is it going to
continue to grow are you gonna do
typical rounds like Roman number one
there were two funding or is there
evergreen fund
how many ventures per year you expect it
to to go with that kind of thing great
question
so it's a little more than a billion
dollars in this fund itself it's a it's
a 20 year fund but you know by no means
does that mean that we're gonna be
likely making our you know like first
investments out of this fund and year
eighteen right so you know it's over the
next few years anywhere we're looking to
really deploy that capital into great
businesses you know for first
investments and then we've got that that
patience on the back end to keep with
the companies as they're moving forward
if you know if building a great company
is gonna take 15 years we can do that
right if it's going to take 18 years we
can do that but we're looking to deploy
that capital earlier in the cycle and
right now you know that this is the fund
and this is the fun we're focused on but
one thing that I'm think that occurred
to me I remember early on and I was
talking to a mentor of mine
what was different about this fun and
was exciting one of the things I said
it's and we've got a billion dollars
that's big and he reminded me in the in
the area of Energy and Climate a billion
dollars is not dumping and so I think
one thing that we're very aware of is
this hast if this is gonna make a
difference this is the beginning of
something this isn't the end of
something yeah I just just got done
teaching my class and we reminded them
that
bp's revenue last year was like a
hundred and eighty five billion dollars
so just one year one company a one last
follow-on on this to is there a sense
you're gonna be putting cash and reserve
for each of your ventures for follow-on
investing or are you looking at seeding
and hoping other people will pick up
more slack down then we're definitely
gonna be reserving capital for companies
and any will do in a different way given
that we're looking to support these
companies for a long haul and these are
often capital intensive businesses I
also say excuse me
relative to the more traditional fund I
think we're gonna be much more you even
more interested in syndicates and
collaboration and co-investment because
these problems are hard and they require
you know a reasonable amount of capital
and we want to make sure that and so
we're you know there are some kind of
investors who are kind of trying to
crowd out others I think we're gonna be
quite the opposite we're looking to pull
in other investors around that the
investments that we're doing time for
maybe one or two more questions someone
asks I didn't see much discussion around
building or building efficiency we all
know that efficiency improvements can
have a huge impact if you guys have is
that part of your thesis or are you more
focused on because individual companies
may be more focused on power sources and
uses is that a reasoning that you're not
focusing on any talk yeah you know
buildings is big so it's something we
care a lot about and I you know you can
only talk about so many things one talk
so I have a slide on buildings but it
didn't present it today I'd say one of
the areas were most interested in
buildings is in zero greenhouse gas
associated heating and cooling that's a
huge portion of all of the energy we use
in buildings
my personal opinion is that lighting
with the advent of LEDs and the rapid
penetration is maybe less of an
important area for us to focus but I
don't think we have a similar innovation
on a similar cost curve in HVAC space
we've also been looking at you know kind
of creative things around the embedded
footprint of buildings that looks back
at materials and so one of my colleagues
is looking very seriously at how do you
expand the envelope of wood based
construction where you know you're
actually you get a two-bagger where
you're you're you're displacing steel
and concrete and you're also
sequestering carbon there through
biomass and so I'd say that there are a
number of areas that were very
interested in buildings but I think
buildings are tough and I ran the
buildings program at DOA it's a tough
space and so you know we're definitely
going to be in there but I think we're
gonna have to do some creative things to
make a real difference there all right
so last question this is a riff on one
that that someone submitted that I'll
add a bit too having fought the fight
personally or not personally but the
company that I founded along with a
bunch of other people Okwe on we went up
against multinationals in the battery
storage space and eventually had a
difficult and acquired at a great loss
so bad the company continues but none of
the initial investors are in the game
and one of the things that we thought of
or you know towards the end was wow we
really should have aligned ourselves
with the multinational early on to
co-develop and make sure that our
particular manufacturing and our
approach was amenable to what was
happening globally with these huge
companies that have were bankable and
had a lot more cash are you guys looking
to encourage this kind of collaboration
early on with these new new companies
yeah a double meeting of that I mean
this is a situation because at some
point if it's a real thing in this
competition it's difficult to keep your
company afloat no I'm I agree with you
wholeheartedly the you know
interestingly so we chose not to have
companies as limited partners in our
fund and I think because we appreciate
that we do need to work with a large
number of these companies to partner you
know I think that might have been a
cleantech one auto weakness in strategy
was is like we're gonna go head-to-head
with these companies as opposed to
finding win-win ways to collaborate and
do I teach a energy ventures class at
Stanford where we try to teach the
connect generation of entrepreneurs the
lessons you know of 1.0 and and what is
what is a playbook a new playbook that
we should be thinking of as company
builders and entrepreneurs in this space
to have better outcomes and you know I
kind of feel like as I look at that
playbook let's say they're you know 10
chapters they kind of like we have five
of them five or six of them that are
reasonably well worked out but I would
say that the chapter on on like how do
you do these win-win strategic
partnerships with the big corporates in
a way that that can preserve and make
sure you can still make money and build
great businesses but leverage the
capabilities of those big companies is
still being written so we're gonna be
engaging in a big way but I think that
there's still a lot of back-and-forth
that needs to happen to make sure that
the the right kinds of deals the right
kind of partnerships get struck perfect
well thank you so much for coming and
spending time with us I think everyone
here I learned a lot I surely did and
come back again frequently thanks
Susanna
so we have now gotten to our lunch time
for today we are currently in the rain
ghost rooms rangos one and two and on
the other side of that wall is rangos
three and that is where all the food is
so we are going to go out these two
doors to the room next door there's
three buffet lines set up so please grab
your food mingle a little bit but we
want to start back here at one o'clock
sharp so make sure you're back by